yeah i got to the point where i won't
say his name because i hear he's a
really nice guy now but back in the day
i was doing a movie with carrie anne
moss and i was the lead bad guy and she
was with our our lead that i'm talking
about and
he just was a real [ __ ] and he just
really was being rude to everybody and
one day cut down a crew member and i
walked up to him and i whispered to him
i said i'm going to [ __ ] knock you
out right now i'm going to knock you out
i'm going to [ __ ] hit you right in
the face if you don't clean up your act
you're just you're just so full of
hubris and [ __ ] these people love
you why why are you behaving like this
it's just inexcusable and he looked at
me and he walked away and he was better
for the next next week and a half or
what i just said i'm gonna [ __ ] punch
right in the face i don't care if i go
to jail i'm gonna knock wow i'm gonna
knock you out because i couldn't take it
anymore i don't i'm not i'm not i mean
i'm far from perfect you know mike but i
got to tell you
the one thing that i learned from my dad
is you stick up for people
that need sticking up for it you [ __ ]
stick you you stick up against the bully